[music playing]
BILLIE MINTZ: I
came here to meet
an extraordinary
man whose vision
stretches far beyond himself.
This is Isaac Nabawana.
OK.
Action.
BILLIE MINTZ: He's committed
to changing the country's image
by making incredibly
violent action
films that are intended to
knock you dead with laughter.
He's a self-taught filmmaker
and Uganda's most prolific,
having made over
50 feature films.
And he's turned a few square
blocks of his neighborhood
into a fully functional
studio back lot.
This is impossible.
This should not exist.
I mean, you see, like
there's no plumbing.
Electricity was good
for a while but now it's
still four days a week maybe.
And making movies.
[beep] it's not possible.
OK, action.
BILLIE MINTZ: Alan
Hofmanis is a super fan
who saw one of Isaac's films
in a Brooklyn bar one night
and immediately got
on a plane to Uganda
to meet the genius behind it.
He never left, eventually
becoming Isaac's co-producer.
I think people are
coming for the same reason
that I'm saying.
This reminds people of why they
love movies in the first place.
Like I'm not an actor, but
you're here for 5 minutes
and you want to do it.
You want to be a commando.
You want to play.
BILLIE MINTZ: The most obvious
theme in all of Isaac's movies
is brutal violence taken
to comedic extremes.
[cheering]
And that's exactly
the point, violence
as an artistic expression,
Isaac believes,
is not only his creative
passion but also
his country's salvation.
You want to clear the picture
of Ugandans killing people
by making films of
Ugandans killing people?
BILLIE MINTZ: Isaac's
over-the-top filmmaking style
strikes a chord here, driving
modest movie ticket and DVD
sales, which the actors are
also able to sell door to door,
thereby supporting the
crew and their families.
And Isaac isn't just
a local celebrity,
he's an international
phenomenon with millions
of hits on YouTube to confirm
his intensely devoted fan base.
[singing]
BILLIE MINTZ: Even more
devoted are the people
who come from all
over Uganda to help
create his micro low
budget full length films.
[applause]
Wow, guys, this
is so impressive.
Any filmmaker in the world, no
matter how successful they are,
would dream to have
a team like you guys.
[applause]